welcome to this video black coffee with
that Grand Master profile I cannot open
the profile that's not good we have some
I have some connection issue here come
on don't tell me I'm disconnected it I
don't want to know it works some delay
going on weird then we want to lose by
this connection once i'm over 2500 again
down line of the English opening I did I
yet unknown name happened okay yeah
going for the french chateau should be
should be okay yeah this some type of
position is always a bit bit funny
because of that that Bishop 185
sometimes a bit unclear what it is
actually doing ok it's going for an e5
maybe if I pass up he has to go h6
though p 5 Bishop c5 is rather awkward I
mean okay probably probably well I will
do it anyway at Bishop seems to me of
questionable value in this position so
I'm going to do that and looking to play
before in the future
you cannot go d5 here or e 5 okay you
can play rook where exactly he can play
something that would be aid so right
back yep let's open up the diagonal 94
quindi one doesn't lead to much and with
this I'm also making sure that be five
is not coming and now be five was that
the idea i have before though and III
I think before and then III is
interesting and III next thoughts I mean
the night doesn't have many squares and
if he goes to check on a three Bishop
takes Queen see 394 looks looks good for
white yeah I thought 94 now would be
quite good or D for as I said before
yeah deform kicks night cheeks that
looks a bit better for white just bit
more active there
no black should be ok everything I think
nothing terrible yeah but I have a
little bit little bit of pressure Queen
a for maybe I wonder if we had some
tactics because both my diets are
unprotected 985 Bishop d7 doesn't lead
to much um but ok maybe I can go Quinn
d3 then yeah or queen d3 immediately
heads to it a bit I am NOT down on time
I was thinking I have a time
disadvantage because I took some time
but he actually spent even more time
now trying to grab that pot maybe you
can play rugby 6 it looks a bit weird
but we don't really see to refute it or
see how to refute it d 5 is not leading
to watch and droopy aid t5
I don't see it leading to much
but should be 74 just grabbing this on a
six that is immensely materialistic and
you can go bien
you
I don't see a good continuation it looks
good but how to how to do something
serious here and d5 maybe it's letter
move maybe maybe this and then d5 that
that could be I have 94 as well let's do
it I don't want to draw even though
timewise I'm a bit down
now maybe you can just go Ruby in going
there okay 96 is not so great okay you
can take a plate e5 after 96 some that
has to be probably avoided
94 would be eight the night ii for that
could be maybe an IDM not sure how
convincing that is though time morning
okay I'm taking that d6 pump can be you
can be really sure that I will do that
let you follow can you go f4 here F for
a queen h5 is awkward okay then go back
25 Knight f6 it's not going to help
925 next well I'm actually when you want
time I really only know so that I'm up
flat all of tides on time is that good
right here I didn't make it a blood let
that point I think okay but anyway yeah
I think I'm a little bit better around
here out out of the opening yeah after
after him he certainly I should probably
go here but I don't know I think white
should be a little bit better my pieces
are a bit more active and it's not so
clear how he's sorting out the screen
side especially with this limited time
that made some sense looking at the week
horn here Brooke here you know I went t
five I didn't want to draw but I wasn't
totally sure about the five exam can
somewhat debatable but the engine likes
it quite a bit it wants to play our
exactly how I played this night here and
now not see foyer 1997 is of course a
mistake but he's under some pressure he
already it's not so clear what you
should do the engine suggests rook f8
which is not a move that any human would
ever play here matt white white white
has a huge advantage here just much more
space and in control of the important
squares until distant was was falling
apart falling apart 3m go back for a
moment i was a bit I really was unsure
if 94 and and this thing was good I
think he can just do this and just stay
yeah I mean I'm not so easily preparing
before in this position and I really
don't see what else I can do at least it
would take some time move like night
each was pretty awkward
so if you just waits that one knew from
I think it makes sense not that this is
a big mistake or anything but I feel he
had time to prepare it while now I'm
actually able to do something with
before and I'm not badly mobilized so I
think I'm he his timing was slightly off
Ian yeah this or queen bee three was
also a play on and here Pierre White is
a little bit better Myra structure is a
bit more a bit more sound and have
really opportunities to get enough
pressure on the queenside to win upon
here and down okay well thanks for
watching